wird der killer asta profis
möglicherweise doch die erde treffen das
leben auf ihr vernichten einer der
entdecker von apophis selbst warnt davor
dass in den bisherigen analysen ein
wichtiger faktor unberücksichtigt
geblieben ist demnach kann nicht
ausgeschlossen werden dass der riesige
brocken im jahr 2068 mit der erde
kollidiert fest steht wenn das passiert
könnte ein gebiet so groß wie ein ganzer
kontinent komplett verwüstet werden
kriegstanz im future hier gibt es drei
mal pro woche spannende science videos
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts was
ganz
herzlich willkommen apophis sein name
ist programm denn benannt wurde der
brocken nachdem gottes chaos und der
finsternis auf seinem weg um die sonne
kreist er alle zwei jahre an der erde
vorbei und klar ist mit seiner größe von
etwa 340 metern durchmesser das
entspricht etwa der länge von drei
fußballfeldern würde er bei einem
treffer mit unserem heimatplaneten einer
region verwüsten die so groß ist wie ein
ganzer kontinent nicht umsonst also
macht der astronomen und astronomen
weltweit große sorgen die ganze welt
hatte ihn im visier und beobachtet seine
flugbahn ganz genau falls ab profis
tatsächlich auf der erde einschlagen
sollte würde dies eine explosion von
knapp einer million tonnen tnt
entsprechen der vergleich mit der zahl
bombe macht die ausmaße deutlich diese
größte nukleare explosion die durch
menschen verursacht wurde entsprach 50
megatonnen tnt klar ist die auswirkungen
auf das gesamte leben auf unserem
planeten wären katastrophal und nicht zu
vergleichen mit asteroiden die bislang
die erde getroffen haben ein großteil
des lebens auf der erde könnte unter
anderem durch fliegende trümmer tsunami
wellen und schlimme erdbeben ausgelöst
werden und zwar von der einen sekunde
auf die andere analysen zufolge würde
apophis falls er auf land einschlägt
einen mindestens fünf kilometer großen
krater in die erde schlagen weitaus
schlimmere folgen aber hätte es wohl
wenn der riesige brocken im mehr
aufschlagen würde tsunamis könnten an
nahegelegenen küsten eine höhe von mehr
als 100 metern haben und selbst ferne
küsten während von etwa 30 meter hohen
flutwellen bedroht ein echtes
katastrophen szenario also bereits vor
17 jahren am 19 juni 2004 hatte ein
astronomie team um den wissenschaftler
david holen vom kitt peak national auf
satori um in arizona einen riesen
brocken aufgespürt und bereits damals
sorgte dieser längliche brocken der
zunächst 2004 m in 4 genannt wurde für
aufregung denn schon damals war klar
dass der asteroid der erde schon bald
relativ nahe kommen wird letztendlich
flog er dann mit einem abstand von
14,41 millionen kilometern an uns vorbei
ein beruhigend große abstand und die
welt atmete auf danach konnte die
fachwelt dann in ruhe sein orbit
bestimmen doch das ergebnis sorgte
erneut für aufregung denn den
berechnungen zufolge sollte der
asteroiden 323 tagen die sonne umrunden
und dabei immer wieder die erdbahn
kreuzen mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
2,7 prozent und das ist eine menge
könnte er diese analyse zufolge am 13
april 2029 die erde treffen ausgerichtet
am freitag den 13 april klar war also
von vornherein dass es sich um einen
killer asteroiden handelt manche nannten
ihn auch ein chaos gut ein jahr nach
seiner entdeckung wurde der spd 2004
empfiehlt deswegen dann auch auf seinen
neuen namen getauft 999 42 apophis
einige astronomen und astronomen hatten
von kurz sind dann die umlaufbahn von
dem asteroiden neu berechnet und dabei
festgestellt dass ein phänomen in
bisherigen berechnungen gefehlt hatte
der sogenannte jakob ski effekt demnach
können die flugbahnen von asteroiden
durch die einstrahlung der sonne
verändert werden und das kann man sich
so vorstellen die sonneneinstrahlung
kann unter bestimmten umständen dazu
führen dass asteroiden ungleichmäßig
erwärmt werden diese wärmeenergie kann
dann asymmetrisch wieder abgestrahlt
werden und genau das hat einen einfluss
auf die flugbahn der asteroid kann in
geringem ausmaß in eine bestimmte
richtung gelenkt werden und kleine bahn
änderungen haben dann bei hohen
geschwindigkeiten und großen distanzen
erheblichen einfluss einer der entdecker
von apophis selbst david owen hatte dazu
vor einiger zeit eine studie
veröffentlicht die große frage die bei
dieser analyse geklärt werden sollten
wie stark ist die abweichungen von
apophis ursprünglichen kurs 18 sehr
präzise aufnahmen gelangen dem
forschungsteam mit hilfe des subaru
teleskops auf dem mauna kea
observatorium hawaii die position des
asteroiden konnte dabei jeweils auf eine
hundertstel bogen sekunde genau bestimmt
werden das ergebnis ist wirklich
spektakulär der jakob ski effekt führt
dazu dass apophis jedes jahr um etwa 170
meter von seiner bislang vorhergesagten
umlaufbahn abweicht auch wenn das erst
einmal nach wenig klingt langfristig
gesehen ist das eine ganze menge die
wärme der asteroid ausstrahlt verleiht
ihm also noch einen extra schub laut dem
forschungsteam müsse man deswegen das
ein schlag szenario für 2068 weiter im
spiel halten um mehr über den jakobsweg
effekt und seine auswirkungen
herauszufinden untersucht die nasa
derzeit ja auch den asteroiden ben und
dieser wird laut berechnung pro jahr um
268 meter in richtung sonne verschoben
da wird auch noch ein video zu kommen
denn da wird sich das anschlagsrisiko
auch verändern wo sie bis rechts von der
nasa soll zeigen wie genau das modell
zur berechnung des jakob ski effekts ist
im besten fall kann es so verfeinert
werden dass die flugbahn von asteroiden
in zukunft noch viel genauer
vorhergesagt werden können das könnte
dann natürlich auch bei den berechnungen
zu apophis zum einsatz kommen später gab
es bezüglich apophis dann auch wieder
entwarnung denn die bahn von apophis
konnte deutlich exakter bestimmt werden
und so konnten die schlimmsten
befürchtungen erst einmal entkräftet
werden denn weder die annäherung des
asteroiden im jahr 2029 noch die
annäherung von apophis im jahr 2068
sollte demnach der erde gefährlich
werden können ein direkter treffer der
erde durch den asteroiden konnte schon
fast ausgeschlossen werden im april
diesen jahres 2021 gab es diese
offizielle entwarnung und die esa hatte
den asteroiden von der liste der
gefährlichsten als du ihnen gestrichen
demnach kann also ein zusammenstoß mit
der erde erst einmal ausgeschlossen
werden die berechnung der fachleute
hatten ergeben dass in den nächsten 100
jahren erst einmal keine kollision mit
unserem heimatplaneten zu befürchten sei
die nasa sieht dem vorbeiflug von
apophis im jahr 2029 stattdessen als
unglaubliche chance für die wissenschaft
demnach wird apophis am 13 2029 in
weniger als
32.000 kilometern entfernung an der erde
vorbei ziehen und kann dabei sogar mit
bloßem auge beobachtet werden denn dann
kommt er uns wirklich nah näher als die
satelliten in der geostationären
umlaufbahn das ist wirklich ziemlich nah
dazu nasa-mitarbeiter polkow dass durch
die beobachtung von apophis während
seines flugs im jahr 2029 werden wir
wichtige wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
gewinnen die eines tages für die
verteidigung des planeten verwendet
werden könnten doch für apophis wird der
vorbeiflug nicht ohne folgen bleiben
dazu der astronom david von nokia wir
wissen bereits dass die nahe begegnung
mit der erde die umlaufbahn von apophis
verändern wird unsere modelle zeigen
auch dass die annäherung die art und
weise wie sich der asteroid dreht
verändern könnte und es möglicherweise
zur oberflächen veränderung die kleinen
lawinen kommen kann heißt also im
klartext dass ich dadurch seine bahn und
aigen rotation erheblich verändern wird
was diese gravitative störung am ende
für folgen haben werden lässt sich zwar
berechnen aber nur sehr ungenau sprich
diese begegnung wird wieder alles
verändern und niemand kann deshalb heute
sagen wie nah profis 2068 in die nähe
der erde kommen wird klar ist aber auch
dass wir noch längst nicht alle objekte
auf dem schirm haben die uns gefährlich
werden könnten und so ist für manche
fachleute eine sache ganz klar für sie
ist es nur eine frage der zeit bis ein
asteroid auf die erde trifft auch der
chef von tesla asics in den mast hat
dazu ein statement über twitter
abgegeben auch er hatte sich dabei auf
apophis bezogen toller name ich würde
mir keine sorgen über genau den machen
irgendwann ist es soweit und ein großer
asteroid wird die erde treffen und wir
haben keine verteidigung genau deswegen
planen nasa und esa bereits für das
kommende jahr den ersten versuch eines
neuartigen asteroiden abwehr verfahrens
schon dieses jahr ist der start der
mission geplant und im oktober 2022 soll
ein asteroid mit einem gezielten
anschlag aus seiner bahn geworfen werden
das steht für double estate redirection
test und dabei will die nasa hat den
kleineren brocken eines doppel ass zu
ihnen befeuern um dessen bahn zu
verändern verteidigung der erde nasa
stadtmission schickt weltraum waffenlos
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
hammer video mit besonders spannende
infos zur mission ein absolutes must
watch video also spätestens jetzt
klicken und ansonsten bis dann bleib
dran